[Applause]
the beauty of this spot on an Alpine
Lake was lost amid the cries of distress
when a man drew a knife in a popular
Park and initiated a vicious attack
he targeted children and their carers in
a playground by the water and there were
some who couldn't get away
in these distressing pictures shot by
bystanders we see the assailant
brandishing a knife
four young children had been stabbed in
the attack at least one while sitting in
a push chair
here park users try to intervene using
their rucksacks like Shields
this an attempt to hinder his Escape
an athlete who was running in the park
remembers what he heard and what he saw
all of a sudden a mother said to me run
run there's someone starving everyone
around the lake you stab children run
run and I was a bit surprised I carried
on I saw the guy basically right in
front of me
the police arrived and pursued the
attacker
a 31-year-old Syrian National who is
also a registered refugee
Mr latalik said the police officers Drew
their weapons
I said to the police shoot him kill him
he's stabbing everyone meanwhile he's
attacking once then twice then the
police began to shoot
the children targeted in this shocking
incident were aged between 22 months and
three years and the authorities say
they've all suffered life-threatening
injuries they're currently being treated
in France and neighboring Switzerland
one child is a British national I can't
emphasize enough how shocking this is
for the people who were having a
peaceful beautiful summer morning in one
of the most beautiful spots on planet
Earth and suddenly this happened and
there are police running everywhere
there are medical
helicopters and Sirens blaring and
everyone's just trying to figure out
what on Earth is happening
the police investigation has begun and
the French prime minister who journeyed
to anisee said it's not thought to be
related to terrorism
all efforts will need to be made but
this is a time for emotion said
Elizabeth
foreign
the attack has traumatized a community
and a nation and it will fuel arguments
about immigration in France
everyone however will pray for the
victims John Sparks Sky News